foreign
[Music]
welcome to the 2022 lab Roots life
science microscopy series my name is
Leia Lavery Marketing Manager for life
science electron microscopy from the
Thermo Fisher Scientific and your
moderator today
welcome back to any returning attendees
and a big hello to new attendees
wherever you are in the world many of
you know Therma Fisher from other life
science areas but I want to introduce
you to the life science electron
microscopy division our division
provides complete workflows from a
cry-electron micro week solutions from
structural determination to macular
complexes and native state and to 3D
reconstruction of image tissues and
cells
so today so we're talking about cellular
cryoelectron tomography which is a high
resolution technique that enables
electron Imaging of molecular Machinery
at a solid close to Native conditions
today's speakers Alex rigard and Michael
Grange will be sharing how cryoelectron
tomography is applied to answer various
biological questions and how the
workflow is enhanced with the
capabilities of the new arctis
cryoplasma fib we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask the question box at any
time and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of today's presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the today's presentation
today's presentation is titled arctis
cryoplasmifib for throughput and
connectivity in cellular cryoelectron
tomography
our speaker Alex rigert works as a
product marketing manager for Thermo
Fisher Scientific he developed and used
cryo-focused IMB instrumentation for
applications in electron tomography at
the Max Planck Institute for
biochemistry in Munich and has more than
15 years experience in cryo-electron
microscopy
our second speaker we welcome from the
Roslyn Franklin Institute Michael Grange
Michael completed his Doctrine
philosophy in structuralogy in the
University of Oxford in the UK where he
applied FIB Milling electron tomography
and super resolution microscopy to
investigate the trafficking and egress
of viral progeny within the cells after
his doctoral studies he moved to the
mass plaque Institute for molecular
physiology in Germany as an embo
long-term fellow during his Fellowship
he established priority as a core method
and was evolved in establishing High
throughput 5 million workflows and
combined them to investigate the
structure and architecture of isolated
mammalian muscle and human stem cell
derived
cardiomycytes in 2021 he joined the
Franklin as a group leader where his
research uses an Institute structural
techniques to determine the impact of
disease relevant genetic alterations on
the structural cell biology of axonal
plasticity with an emphasis on
cytosoluting trafficking and structural
alterations with the neuron he also
develops methods for priority and the
correlative Imaging of larger tissues
and structural studies
so Therma Fisher and Roslyn Franklin
have been working together since 2019 to
determine really what's next for crying
before we get our talk let's take a
quick look at Visit to the RFI via this
video
the Rosalind Franklin Institute is
really the sort of brainchild of Sir
John Bell John had this idea that the UK
needed to have a high risk High reward
Institute and that Institute would be
focused on our understanding of disease
and the new treatments and cures for
some of the diseases that afflict us the
goal of the Franklin is to change how we
think about some of the most complex
diseases and therefore find better ways
to treat them
the whole point of cryo electron
tomography is we're going to look inside
the cell for what the protein is doing
inside the cell so normally what does it
look like inside the cell who's it
talking to who are its neighbors and
what's the consequence of those
interactions we're very interested in
being able to look inside the tissue of
model systems and look for the early
stages of the disease as a means to cure
that disease I think is is really an
exciting possibility the Roslyn Franklin
Fisher have been collaborating really
since 2018 on the development of new
plasma FIB Technologies that's now come
into being with the arctis machine and
that's a brand new plasma FIB which is
highly automated and powerful machine
that's going to simplify the workflow
for groups across the world and what
we've been working with them or to do is
to make this technology easy to use and
as applicable as possible because
there's a power comes from when
everybody can apply a technique to these
big problems
we are entirely collaborative here at
the Franklin we've worked with thermal
for a number of years with us visiting
thermal and then we're coming to visit
us but it's not just stanmore that come
here we have collaborations across the
UK and across the world with people we
share ideas and Share technology and so
we're all in the same race against these
diseases not with each other but it's
against
thank you very much Leah for this
introduction and also on behalf of
Michael and myself
welcome to this arctis Kyle plasma flip
webinar
yeah the active system is our new sample
preparation system for electron
tomography and I want to give you here a
quick overview about the principle of
ceiling cells for tomography you can see
the active system on the left hand side
this is a focused I-beam system in this
case we have a plasma focused iron beam
source
what we do with the OCTA system is we
are sealing cells down to make them
electron transparent so that we can
image them in the transmission electron
microscope you can see the cryos G4 here
in the middle of the slide
so what the arctis does is it produces
an iron beam that we can direct site
specifically to a frozen hydrated cell
this cell is typically residing on an
electron microscopic grid and then we
use this beam to thin it down to Middle
away cellular material and thereby
create a thin electron transparent
lamella this Lamela are called in situ
La Melia and provide an A View into the
Frozen hydrated interior of the cell
once we have prepared the cell in that
way we can transfer the lamella into the
transmission electron microscope this is
again the cryos that you can see here in
the transmission electron microscope we
acquired the thermocrine and we do that
in the following way we are not rotating
the electron Source around the sample
instead we tilt the sample under the
Electron Beam and acquire a so-called
thermographic tilt Series so many
different images of the sample a
different tilt angles and from these
still seals we can then back project
into a tomochrome and then create the
the tomographic image and that's what
you can see here so and the advantage of
such a thermal kremise of course that it
not only provides information about the
structural
details of individual proteins but also
contextual information about the
proteins residing into Insider the
cellular context
tomography can be done on a range of
different types of samples so that's
summarized in this slide
there are different thicknesses of the
different objects if you want us to take
a look at the left hand side protein
virus particles those can be plant
Frozen and they don't require sinning at
all because they are thin enough so you
can directly image them in the
transmission electron microscope
but whenever you go to more complex
samples and they can even start from
Material cells over to to eukaryotic
cells then up to larger objects like
tissue cells small organoids or then
even black tissues more organisms then
definitely some way of ceiling is
required to make the sample accessible
for transmission electron microscopy and
that's why we need to have the focused
imbeam instrument the arctis system to
make the samples accessible for
tomography so a lot of these samples are
Frozen by the ways of plant freezing
when the objects get thicker and you
need to freeze objects that are larger
than 5 or 10 microns then we have to
refer to high pressure freezing which is
a method which can vitrify objects up to
200 microns
this freezing type produces more bike
samples so here again different
techniques have to be applied to to work
them with these samples in general what
we do for most samples on crits we
prepare as I explained before this in Z2
La melee on the grid So within the cells
or the objects directly on the grid as
you will see later we can do that with
the arctis also for some cells that we
fuse in so-called waffle Lamela methods
or thin ice discs where we kind of use
the iron beam specialty the plasma beam
to remove bulk eyes and then produce
large lamales from that sample and then
if we go through more complex samples
like bulk tissue or even small organisms
or something which is Frozen in what you
can see on the right hand side here
plungered sample then there are
different techniques applied for
instance um the chiral lift out
technique so in general tomography works
for a large range of different samples
these samples have different
requirements for freezing them either by
plunge freezing or high pressure
freezing for most of these samples it is
required to send them down to make them
accessible for tomography and that's why
the cryophib Milling technique is so
important and why we also have the
arctis system for this essential step of
sample preparation for tomography
there was this I would like to end this
short introduction and pass it on to
Michael to give you a short introduction
into the Rosalind Franklin Institute and
his work at the RFI
Michael over to you
yeah thanks Alex so before I actually
delve into some of the applications that
we're using the actors for
um I'd just like to briefly introduce
the Russian Franklin Institute
uh the Roslyn Franklin Institute was
established to fill a gap in the UK life
science sector
as a place where high risk High reward
Technologies can be developed that may
not actually be possible at other
institutes across the UK and its Mission
really is to bring together physicists
chemists and life scientists to promote
and develop technologies that may
otherwise
impact on key challenges in health and
life sciences
one key area that was identified was
electron carotomography
which due to the fact that it can image
molecules in tissues and in cells has
promise of being a technique where it
may be possible to develop an era of
atomic pathology
and and my group is really investigating
different aspects of neurobiology to be
able to try and probe sleep cytoskeletal
organization and axonal organization and
really the the goal is to be able to
determine structures in situ that are
only possible through this means
um so this is work by Ava who is a
postdoc in my group and she's
investigating the role of trim 46 in
bundling micro trivials and
understanding their requirement for
maintaining acts on polarity
how this occurs is actually not well
understood
um and the structures of how these
materials are fasciculated by term plus
X is not known so we're actually trying
to develop methods to recapitulate this
in vitro
fall structure determination and this
really needs correlative methods that
are able to Target specifically labeled
cells for creatine ideally that needs to
be a coincident on the Fly
and we've actually been extending this
further to primary cells where we try to
Target proximal regions to the SoMo
which are important in maintaining
neuronal polarity so this is some of
Jake's work who's a PhD student who's
been trying to Target the apps on
initial segments neurons are quite
diverse so we need to be able to Target
regions specifically to understand their
role and their function
and this is important if we want to get
an idea and a handle on how cytoskeletal
organization achieves this
and we've been using the actors to
generate lamella of these practical
regions and on the right you can see one
such region where you see microtubules
and tubules which I'm uh studied with
the membrane protein endophylline and
this can be seen on a molecular scale
now obviously targeting is one aspect of
um of this workflow but the other is
actually being able to produce High
volumes of data from multiple different
cell types and the reason why that's
important is because if we take a
disease model and we want to investigate
mutations relevant to disease we
actually have to be able to take cell
lines and
identify features that are mapped onto
isogenic controls and so because
um the axis has 12 grids at a time and
that we can actually have proficient
screening and Sample loading in a low
contamination environment we now have
the tool which allows us to really try
and push the applicability of this so
Bronwyn is a PhD student who's working
at
um
patient derived samples to investigate
molecular changes and then the lysosomal
system
and she's going to be able to build up
enough data to actually use machine
learning to add to match and investigate
changes in that system across different
cell types
and so she can investigate enough
controls enough mutable lines to
actually begin to get statistical
groundings for observations
and it's not just you know neuronal
cells that we can look at we also can
start to look at pathogenic
um problems in this case uh this is some
of Helena Watson's work who's a PhD
student in gymnastics group
where she's studying the effect of
antiviral bacterial defense mechanisms
where
um when activated a TR Tiara saved
protein assembles into filament to
structures
and this happens in vitro but actually
how does it occur inside bacteria how
does this occur um at different stages
of bacterial pathogenesis
and so they've been using that just to
actually Mill lamella and take
cryothermography data of these bacteria
where they can observe these filamental
structures
and so really the goal of the electron
chronicomography project at the RFI and
our collaboration with Thermo is really
to try and increase throughput and to
increase the ease at which
cryotomography can be implemented so
that you simply have to
Define your project identify ways you
want to Target locate that object using
either Optical microscopy or other means
transferring those samples simply
shaping the sample so that you can then
perform electron cryptomography
performing electron card tomography and
then finally
applying machine learning and different
segmentation and so from average methods
to actually molecularly characterize the
data
and this is actually something that's
desperately needed
so this is a slide that I put together
with Sebastian Tucker and Dartmouth
around 2020 where we were trying to
understand the cryotron tomography and
C2 structural biology landscape
um at that time and you can see that it
the workflow was really fragmented so
each box represents uh sort of
individual handling step or a point
where you might have to transfer between
a different
um apparatus
and they really were quite a lot of
manual steps which gives a lot of room
for error
um you know spending time off with a lot
in grids in order to achieve the right
orientation for the tomography or moving
it to different modality and all of
which have different effects on data
quality either contamination or changes
from the ideal to access which can lead
to aberrations or a sort of
deterioration in your sample quality or
your automogram quality at the end point
and so the idea was really to simplify
all of this so that you can handle the
samples robotically under a vacuum
implementing correlative methods that
can be performed concomitantly
and so that everything is more
simplified and all the transfer steps or
the majority of the transfer steps are
removed
and the microscopy landscape at the
rosary Frank industry looks like this we
have a Helios Hydra which we call
Rosalind which was uh the first
instrument which enabled us to get
Hands-On with plasma to understand how
how different it might be to gallium
um
to use fluorescence targeting I'll be in
this case of access and we're also able
to explore serial FIB Sam to to perform
volumetric Imaging of tissues and cells
we then took delivery of our prototype
artists which
took into account all of the different
workflow aspects that we want to improve
and this was the first of a Kind p-fib
where it has extended operation time so
it can be used for more than a week more
specimens apart and coincident
fluorescence
and we also have a cryos G4 which we
call Dorothy which has an extended tilt
range
um has a such as Falcon far in his
crosstem capable
and with that I'd like to hand over to
Alex who will tell you more about the
Actis itself
let me go into a little bit more details
on the the active system and see how
that's positioned in the tomography
workflow here you can see again the
workflow with the essential steps from
the side culture over the verification
step into the lamella making and the
correlated for microscube that we do
with the arctis system until the temp
tomography part where we acquire the 3D
information from the sample and process
it
on the OCTA system we use a different
type of focus ion beam compared to the
gallium-based system on an aquil loss so
here we utilize a plasma focused iron
beam that comes from an inductively
coupled plasma iron source
so the way the the beam is formed you
can see on this slide
we have different gas species that we
can utilize to form different plasma
beams so in our case the non-argon on
oxygen so the gas comes from small
cylinders which is kind of going into a
plasma cell in the imbm column we couple
in energy into that plasma cell ionizing
the gas species and then applying
extraction Optics to extract the ions
collimate them and focus them into a
beam that then is used to sputter away
material on the on the system there are
certain advantages on the plasma beam
most of all there's no gallium
implantation compared to a liquid metal
iron source and of course the plasma
beam also has excellent fine milling and
bike material removal capabilities that
we can use on the arctis system
here's a more detailed view of the
technology of the arctis so you will see
what is behind the the enclosure here on
the schematic on the right hand side you
can see key components some of these
components are derived from TM
technology such as the autoloader and
the compostage so the auto loader SC
robotic loading system that enables us
to load up to 12 grits into the arctis
system the crits are picked up with a
compute stage
the sample can then be manipulated with
the plasma Fib so also with the focused
iron beam we have an sem column to image
the sample and provide navigational
capabilities for the first time we also
have a light microscope at The
Coincidence point of all three beams of
the iron beam Electron Beam and the
light microscope beam here so that
enables us to do light microscopy at the
same position where we also do the
Milling so we will need to move to an
external position for light microscopy
Imaging in the system
we made sure that the system is well
shielded in terms of contamination
protection with a dedicated Kyle box we
also made a complete redesigned vacuum
chamber for that
purpose and we also have other
capabilities on the system such as the
gas injection system the gis system
which provides the protective coating
for producing in Z2 La Medi as well as a
sputter Target that we can move in and
then knock on with the power of the plus
and fit beam to produce a conductive
very thin nanometer thick coating
conductive coating onto the sample which
is important for later data acquisition
entity the whole system as you can see
on the left side is in a biosafety
enclosure providing a shielding from the
environment to the interior of the of
the system
this slide shows you the sample loading
of the arctis system with the autoloader
what you can see here is a cut open view
of the robotic sample loading system so
once the user has loaded samples to this
outer loader the system will pick up the
samples the samples are in a cassette
that holds 12 good positions
and then we have a Clipper arm which
picks one of these grids and moves it
into the high vacuum chamber into the
compute stage and once we have the
sample in the compute stage we can
manipulate it with the iron beam image
it with the Electron Beam and also
utilize the fluorescence light
microscope to detect fluorescence from
the sample
another novelty on the Arctic is the new
sample carrier the tomocrit you can see
that on this slide here so this is what
we call the tomocrit
um it's important to have a auto loader
compatible kit carrier system
traditionally such autocrats were around
objects and the reason why we gave the
tomokit two flat sides as shown here on
the left side
in the tem system we have to load the
auto crits into the compule stage and
for the lamella use case it's quite
important that the lamella Milling axis
is aligned well to the temp tilt axis
ideally the tempted XS is 90 degree
perpendicular to the Milling axis and by
giving the new cut carrier the two more
credit is flat sides we can make sure
that we always have the correct
orientation of the fit Milling axis
towards the temp tilt axis so that we
can maximize also the the area that we
can obtain during tilting the sample
because if you have a sample which is
not well aligned as you see here and
that can cause that we get some
shadowing when we kind of tilt the
sample and that loses or that causes
then that we not have the full area
accessible for tomography data
acquisition so this is kind of solved
here with the new Tomoka concept that
makes sure that the meeting access is
perfectly aligned to the tempted axis
the arctis system always comes with an
integrated light microscope this slide
microscope is mounted at the beam
coincidence position you see that in the
schematic here on the left hand side
so the light microscope is mounted
underneath and we can image the sample
there's a way to flip the compute stage
180 degrees so in case we are Imaging
Seeker samples we can do that from both
directions we can manipulate the sample
at the same position with the iron beam
and image it with the Electron Beam and
also obtain the fluorescence information
straight from that same coincidence
point so there is no need to move to an
external Imaging position a light
microscope
we have the objective with the pH so
that is part of the high vacuum chamber
and then on the light path we pass a
vacuum window here the excitation comes
from an LED light source and the
emission pathway once we pass the die
correct we go here through an emission
filter before we go to a CMOS camera on
the system now the advantages that we
don't need to move to an external uh or
kind of a an off axis light microscopy
image position we can keep the sample in
the same position where we put ucular
melee as you can see in this small
animation movie so we have Imaging of
sem light microscope and also the iron
building all at the same coincidence
point with that system the objective we
are using here is a 100x objective with
a numerical aperture of 0.75 at the
working distance of 4 millimeters
foreign
we are also developing a new user
control software for the arctis the idea
here is to go away from a variety of
single packages that are needed to
prepare lamelli from cells and to
provide rather comprehensive unified
user interface with a full lamella
population can be done within that
single software so we call that the
Actis user interface it's accessible
from anywhere so that means there's no
need to sit next to the microscope to
control it to do the lamella preparation
but go for instance to a computer room
or to the office test then access the
actors where they are web and what you
see will be a web user interface like
this which gives you first of all an
overview about the samples which are
loaded into the system so the outer
loader as I mentioned before has 12
different sample positions you can see
here there's a couple of samples couple
of different samples which are loaded
into the 12 positions the first thing in
this user interface will be to acquire
the crit overview Maps that's something
the system is doing autonomously after
sample loading so you can see here there
will be a gallery of different samples
which are loaded to the system now you
can access individual samples by
clicking on these Galleries and that
will provide the grid overviews that's a
map of the kits that are loaded into the
system where the user now can select
regions where lameli should be prepared
there will be also some templates that
can be adjusted to the different
specimens that are loaded so each
specimen may have some different Milling
parameters those parameters can be
stored in the template and then recalled
and then the system will present to the
user the Milling sites and then it's up
to the user to define whether the meta
should be placed and how the pattern
parameters
um should look like so there's some
flexibility to adjust this
after this this information is stored to
the system and the system then starts to
process the sample autonomously until
the final The Meta is produced so that
it really goes down all the way until a
final Amino production final position
and of course there will be also a
function to integrate the light
microscopy information into that
workflow
so that is done before to identify
regions of interest but also after
Alameda is being produced we can use the
light microscope like it is shown here
to to check the fluorescence in the
prepaid La Media directly on the system
so that's the software concept behind
that screen work in progress but gives
you an idea on the uh the concept here
yeah before we take a closer look at the
application work with the arctis I would
like to give an overview on the type of
samples that we can process with this
new system and I would like to start you
first with samples which originate from
plant freezing so you can see here the
schematic of the technique so it's one
of the most versatile techniques that is
used today to prepare cellular samples
for tomography it works for a variety of
different cells or both adherent cells
or suspension cells or cells which are
grown on grids whether that be a primary
cells or cell lines they can be frozen
by plant freezing technique by immersing
immersing them into liquid e-same very
rapidly that will cause the cells
embedded in the individuals layer of ice
these grids which are prepared in that
way they are then clipped into the new
thermocrit carrier and then the goal is
of course to produce as many lamelli on
the greatest possible we do that in the
in the way I explained it before was on
the grid thinning I put using this in
Zito Chio de melee and the clear task
and goal here for the Arctic is to do
this type of Lamela production with a
much higher throughput and then we have
done that before on the existing higher
ship systems
I mentioned in the beginning in my
overview of samples that can be used for
tomography there are also thicker
samples which require a second technique
to vitify them and that's high pressure
freezing so we can also work with high
pressure Fusion samples with the arctis
system and in a way that doesn't require
a lift out system you can see that on
this slide so this gives you an example
on the the way these samples are
produced so we have a grid which is
sandwiched in between a high pressure
freezing plant sheds so these are the
the components that go into the high
pressure freezer on the sample on the
kit we can have an hour more bike sample
that can be for instance a small
organoids that we we can use here to
freeze it in that way the grid is
sandwiched in between the two plant
cells those planchets go into the high
pressure freezer then the main principle
of the high pressure freezer is to apply
a high pressure which in turn lowers the
freezing point of water so in The
Advocate can verify objects up to
approximately 200 microns in thickness
the outcome of such a sandwich could hpf
freezing experiment is a frozen disk
bike material which is vitrified on the
grid also called a waffle grid and that
contains a sample now which is embedded
in bike eyes now such a good can be
loaded into the thermocrit carrier that
I explained before
and here's the real advantages of the
plus of 15 because initially we need to
really remove a lot of bike ice material
before we can start to do Lamela Milling
geometry so the idea here is really to
use the plasma beam to first cut out
make this half Cuts removing bike ice
material from such samples and then we
can utilize the beam to make a lamella
with the same geometries that are
conceptually similar like in Zito La
Mali and that way we can produce
relatively large lamellis so that's also
what has been described in the waffle
technique paper and the blossom flip is
for such a preparation of course
advantageous because large volumes of
ice need to be removed and that's a
faster doable with the plaster beam
compared to the to the gallium fib
I would like to turn it now over to
Michael to talk a little bit about the
application work
um here in the group is doing at RFI
yeah thanks Alex
um I'd just like to spend a bit of time
to go through some attempts we've been
making to characterize plasma and
try to get handle on on how the actors
might perform and this is worked by
Casper Burger more demo and Thomas Glenn
and we've been using that just to
explore automated milling and what we
can achieve with Plasma in this case we
used argon and on the left you can see
how the grids look an example of of a
lamella generated via Argon
um the lamel looks smooth it looks
uniform and and with very little
curtaining
and from the FIB view it looks thin
and we're able to get 26 lamella from 34
initial positions in an automated
fashion most of these were lost after
the roof Milling step
um
and each lamella took approximately 45
minutes to Mill and polish without any
user intervention and this was really a
trying to map the known protocols from
gallium onto the Argon plasma just to
see how it performs and what results may
be able to get if we just sort of use
plasma
um in a vanilla fashion so that's you
know what two Nano amps roof Milling
approximately 2.2 Nano amps
um
media milling and then polishing with
with pequap scale currents
and of these 26 lamella that we
generated we were able to acquire
tomograms on 18 of them you know and
this was the last lack of tomograms on
some of them was due to Classic issues
relating to you know Punch Brothers and
cells cracks in the grid bad eyes
you know problems with the vitrification
or just there not being any regions of
Interest
but you can see that the lamella that we
can produce have have nice features they
have rough ER they have rnp vaults
rubber nuclear protein volts
microtubules cop vehicles can be readily
identified so this gave us confidence
that you know that the lamella were good
that we could get good results from
these data
but before we
went through to survive averaging we
want to get a handle on on kind of what
thickness we generate with the plasma
and how what the profile of those
lamella are
and surprisingly when we looked into the
details of our tomagrams and analyzed
the thicknesses
um the thickness of the timer grams was
quite High there's quite a large
distribution
so the average thickness is 250
nanometers but it varies from 150
nanometers up to around 380 400
nanometers which from you from you is
quite a surprise because often
particular Miller have been difficult to
image
typically the features are quite low
contrast in thicker specimens
but this you know this is this gear is a
this is quite promising because if you
can get good data from thick specimens
you know then there's no need to have a
very thin lamella
and there's a chance to get more volume
of your sample of Interest
and just to let you judge for yourself
here's some example tomagrams from
um from different thicknesses
where on the left you have 138
nanometers and on the right 350 and all
the other contrast on the left looks a
bit better you can still identify plenty
of ribosomes on the thick tomogram
compared to the thin so
this this made us think that actually
they might be able to contribute
somewhat to the supply managing
um and give
high resolution data
and indeed we're able to map the
positions of ribosomes across our 180
tomograms and determine the structure of
of the human ribosome from our healer
cell data to a resolution globally of
4.9 but you can see from the the local
resolution map a lot of this resolution
is at 3.8 which for us is close to the
Nyquist limit of the tomography data
that we acquired
and importantly it's
particle contributions to this structure
still include some of those thick
atomograms and they're not just simply
removed after classification which is
quite promising
we use the warp and rely on Pipeline to
determine the structure
with one line reconstruction using
anatomo
this includes 15 600 ribosomes from
around 149 tomagrams
and
um the 60s subunit is around 4.3
globally and you can see side chains so
you can see that this really is a
pseudo-atomic resolution
um and so plasma really does allow us to
get actually pseudoatomic resolution
scale information from cells
um and one question that's been
asked a lot is what is the kind of
effect of Plasma on on damage to the
lamella and how that might impact on
some type of averaging
um
and so considering how thick our data
are like how much of that is really
usable how
far into the lamella does the plasma
iron beam actually impart damage
and so we've been making some first
steps to try and characterize this
damage layer which is in a way that's
relevant for some volume averaging and
to the ability to determine structures
on a pseudotomic scale
so what we did is actually map particle
distance from The lamella Edge and
compared the ability to reconstruct
particles within and without that space
to a high resolution
and for a distance of 30 nanometers from
The Edge we identified 2099 particles
which were able to determine the
structure for
this structure went to 9.2 angstroms and
we then took 2099 particles from random
positions throughout our data in the
center of our lamella and determine the
structure from those and that went to
eight angstroms
and so possible is close to the edge to
actually not reconstruct to as high
resolution indicating that there is a
reduced alignment capability of
particles close to the edge which we
attribute to particle damage
the particles close to the surface had a
larger B factor meaning that you need
more of those particles to actually
reconstruct to the same resolution
and what we take away from that is that
this could have consequences for very
thin lamella where
um the damage could potentially be
all if not if not the majority but all
of the usable space
and so
the fact that we can get thicker
tomograms from plasma generate lamellar
and still get usable contrast it is
quite a positive in in my view
and so now I'll hand over to Alex who
actually tell you more about the work
that uh he and the opportune I've been
doing to characterizes in on
um
plasma
yeah thanks very much Michael so I would
like to show you now a little bit of the
work we have been done utilizing the
Xenon Beam on the plasma flip system
and what you can see here is the lamella
that has been prepared using the Xenon
beam it's a chlamydomona cell uh we sent
that down to 55 nanometers exceptionally
sin La Mela so the 55 nanometers we
measured on the tomocan we took from
that lamella sample you can see a slice
from the tomochrome on the right hand
side which clearly shows that Tyler Coit
membrane system where you can see the
photosystems also visible
um so this is a very similar Melody that
we have produced with the xenome beam
and that shows us that we can actually
put use high quality data thin data with
the with the Xenon beam it will not be
always required to have such thin
samples but the capability to produce
thinner samples also allows us of course
to go for higher resolution uh in the TM
later
consistency is of course very important
in the in Zito lamella production so you
can see that here for the for the
automated lamella
preparation these are a number of
lamelli sites that have been defined and
then automatically milled with the
system down to the final polishing step
so there's no manual re-polishing or
kind of final polishing work needed for
these samples they can be now
transferred directly into the TM system
these are the corresponding lamella
sides after transferring the TM you can
see here some low Mac overview images of
the lamellas produced the combination of
the uh the automation software which can
automatically produce this similar males
as well as the better connectivity with
the autoloader gives us now the chance
to really produce a lot of the metals
from samples on the grid with higher
consistency and thereby we can also get
of course more areas that we can utilize
for tomography data acquisition
yeah this slide shows that we can
reliably produce lamelli with a sequence
of less than 200 nanometers utilizing
the the Xenon Milling
um what we do to measure out the
thickness of a la meta is the following
so we typically take three thermograms
one kills the front edge of the lamella
one in the middle and one of the end of
the back end of the lamella and then we
average the thickness from these three
thermograms to yield the average
thickness of the lamella
from the thermograms we measure the
thickness by looking at the Z height of
the tomochrome that's the most precise
way to measure this and that's how we
establish the data points so this shows
100 cryola melatonal crimes which are
which we took here the average thickness
is around 130 nanometers so you can see
here that we are definitely able to
produce very similar melee with the
xenome beam so the cylinder melee will
allow us to go to to higher resolution
I mentioned it before it will not be
always required to prepare such
cinderelli and Michael also showed
results that were obtained from zika La
melee but it gives us confidence that we
can utilize the system for a range of
preparing different samples
yeah it's exciting times utilizing a
plasma FIB system for high automography
sample preparation and I think there are
two things here with the new arctis
system that brings a better connectivity
from the FIB to the TM so that's what
you see on the right hand side here so
the auto loader to Auto loader La meta
transfer enables us to produce also
cleaner lamelli which are less
contaminated so that increases
throughput on the areas that we can use
to acquire thermographic data on and
there are I think also new prospects
when we compare the Plus or 52 for
instance the gallium flip systems and
that comes from the fact that we see I
think a better quality in the plasma
field prepared lamelli of course one has
to compare very accurately the same
signal same Imaging conditions on
gallium versus plasma flip data but what
we see is I think that we get a bit
better contrast out of the plasma filter
melee and that would mean that we need
for answers less particles to obtain a
certain resolution compared to gallium
where we may need more particles to get
to the same level of resolution the
reason we'll have to do something with
the different Dynamic damage mechanisms
um that occur on plasma and gallium
Milling gallium for sure as a
disadvantage that there's more
implantation of metal ions into the
sample
compared to to plasma FIB um Michael
showed some data on assessing the damage
for a plasma flip system so I think
there's a lot of prospects in utilizing
the plaster FIB for subterm welcome
averaging and as more data becomes
available we will see um how that
evolves
yeah we also use a button cell the
features such as the ribosomes to
Benchmark the resolution that we can get
out of the plasma flip data you can see
that we can get quite some high
resolution from really small amounts of
data already on the pfib systems the
left side shows an example we have done
in collaboration with the max plan
Institute and Martin Street that's done
on a yeast particles looking at the
yeast ribosomes and you can see here uh
overall 6.5 axle resolution structure
obtained from a singular meta so that's
seven total comes which yielded 7000
particles
on the right hand side you can see that
we can also merge the particle pool to
increase the available particles so this
is from 16 thermal carbs on the
kilometer Mona cell using 5.5 angstrom
resolution here so clearly showing the
way where we're going to really push
also resolution subterm welcome
averaging as we make the tomography
sample preparation more consistent uh
utilizing the plasma Focus time beam
system
with this we are coming to the end of
this webinar
um we really hope that you were able to
learn our sample preparation with the
cryoflip system for tomography works and
how that enables insights into cellular
environments
we also hope that you were able to see
how the new arctis system can really be
used to streamline the production of
lameli from cellular samples bringing
higher throughput and better
connectivity to the tomography workflow
thanks again for attending and Michael
and I we're both happy to answer some
questions
well thank you very much gentlemen for
the great presentations
it looks like we have a few questions
so I'll first ask uh the first question
that you guys are welcome
uh the first question is
um is it necessary to cryo-cycle the
arctis frequently there are quite a bit
of debris there's accumulate on the
sample please describe the situation
yeah so I I can pick that one so
um you have to do it once a week I would
say so it's not much different than to
the to the TM systems where I do a Kyle
cycle so once a week uh coming in up and
then uh recite kind of cycling that's
sufficient so there's a lot of cold
surfaces inside which kind of trap a lot
of the contaminants that come from the
Milling so
um yeah it's not needed more than once a
week and it means also it can run them
for um a week autonomously on the on the
nitrogen viewer
and I also say
we have time for questions if you
haven't had a chance um please submit it
and the answer or the chat box and we'll
be sure to get to it okay the next
question
um what are the differences between each
available gas during Milling
Michael you want to say something to
that
yeah
um well there's obviously the difference
in the Chemistry Between the gases
and
um the jury is still out as to which
what which gas will be the best for
Milling of in using the plasma iron beam
of course which is part of what we're
trying to do with the rfis to try and
assess these different gases for their
propensity to produce curtains to Mill
at different rates
um but yeah so generally
the the atomic number the less
penetrative they are but they also will
cause more damage within that certain
layer that day rather than the sample as
well there is the fact that you have the
atomic number but also you know the
chemistry much different so in the case
of nitrogen and oxygen there may be
secondary effects but we still have to
work that out
yeah I think there's a lot of things
that that really needs to be worked out
still it's not that there's a let's say
a best suited iron yet so I mean there's
a ability to explore the the iron
um the different Iron species for for
building these samples and that's I
think I would say still ongoing work but
generally Xenon is you know Xenon is
faster has a faster spot yield than
argon
um and nitrogen oxygen are in between
that
um and gallium is slightly slower than
oxygen with the data that was measured
so far
okay so I think as a related question I
something was do you expect to Mill also
thinner lamella with argon or is it only
possible with z9 so
so
um The Assault needs optimization right
so you know we did some first tests on
healer cells
um but we we're still trying to optimize
our recipe maybe we try and get thinner
but we just took a an empirical approach
where we tried to aim for a thickness
with around 200 nanometers and we see
what we get from a Dutch Mill Run but I
think it's possible to get vanilla
Miller with argon it you know Alex's
better show that was Xenon you can get
thinner lamella than what we obtained
but I think
um the proof of the pudding isn't is in
the data acquisition and then the
results from the tomography so
okay all right um another the next
question then is um is there a
difference between the sem Columns of
the aqualos and the arctis or are they
the same
foreign
they are not exactly the same so we use
a slightly modified column that is also
in use on the on the Oculus but it's
really modified for the for the new
system to kind of also meet all the
requirements in terms of working
distances and how that kind of relates
to
um you know to the to the alignments of
the of the optic system so it's a
modified uh column we are using there
okay
um it's also related um I have a
question about the the Tomo grid so can
these new clip Rings also be used in the
aqueous 2 and the cryos G4
well first of all they are compatible
with the auto loader systems of the of
the trials so and also dictation systems
so that's the most important thing that
they are Auto load are compatible we
couldn't similarly also use them on the
on the acrylots but we would need to do
some modifications on the shuttles to
really hold them so that's not done yet
but um that's something which could be
the answer but at the moment it's really
uh the autoloader compatibility which is
the kind of Prime Focus for for that new
type of goods because we can really go
then from Auto loader to Auto loader
systems without any extra step and any
thing on the aqueducts would require to
modify slightly the Shepherds for
instance
okay
um also maybe stay with these kind of
Echoes questions uh can they Aqua those
two be upgraded to the arctis
that will be a difficult job so
I think the answer is no okay all right
maybe uh move on to the questions about
the the light microscope so what is the
aqua
yeah so it's a good question so the I
mean the actual resolution is the most
critical is most critical for doing the
exact targeting if you really want to to
Target within I don't know 200 nanometer
normally
um and I think the the resolution is not
better than let's say two microbes so
that's a caveat because we have to use
this uh non-immersion low end a
objectives the point is to use a Point
um seven five lens so we are around two
microns in um
in the exterior resolution
but even if you would use a 0.95 lens
you would not be able to go without one
micron so I mean this is kind of the
intrinsic limitation of this um type of
objectives that we are using so we have
to imply some other uh yeah kind of
methods to kind of overcome this
limitation forms of some fiduciary based
correlation or techniques like this
okay
um and another question Louise is
um in your slide 19 are like one two
three points used for the alignment of
the light microscope image and the sem
image
in your slide okay I think I got it so
it's uh yeah so um basically I mean we
can flip the stage also 180 degrees so
if we have a Seeker sample we can image
it with the light microscope from let's
say the top and if we are not seeing it
from the bottom side we can kind of flip
it and then image it
um from the other side so
if you are not flipping it and if you
just keep your sample uh in the Milling
position and you can image the the
sample from underneath with the light
microscope then there's technically no
need to kind of do a correlation because
you're not moving anything so
um uh when we flip it there may be a
slight correlation that is that that can
be done to align to the sem image
um but I think one of the advantages is
having it at the same coincidence point
is that we don't need to do this kind of
correlations
um that we would normally do if we come
from an external system where we need to
import spatial coordinates and align it
to the SM so that's the advantage of
having it in one point okay
um how precisely does the light
microscope estimate the position of a
fluorescent signal in the z-axis to the
Target position of the interest in the
cell
additionally can light microscope and
use simultaneously during Milling to see
a signal and make sure that it will not
Mill away any position of Interest
Michael you want to say something should
I go first I mean well so the actors
that we've been developing at the RFI
right so is a is a prototype so the the
Optics on our are slightly different I
think to the commercial at the moment so
we don't have a full answer to that at
our Institute
um but typically I would you know
300 in x y and two Micron and Z is
typically the values
so yeah we we have a lot of work to do
to
um to optimize our fluorescence Imaging
and coincidence remaining so we can get
the targets probably localized yeah
that's our experience yeah I mean this
is one of the essential questions and I
mean there are some techniques to kind
of overcome that
um I think having the capability to also
build and simultaneously check for
instance the Milling outcome with the
light microscope is definitely an
advantage to also see step wise where we
are we're still Milling there are also
some Publications coming up where you
localize the fluoroform in your cell and
Su mil you kind of detect the loss of
fluorescence inside the fluorophore to
as an indication that you're kind of
closer to the Target I mean so there are
some ways to to to get more precise but
it's of course still a challenge also to
really get this targeting accuracy to
the point that you always
foreignty that we kind of catch the
under the fluorescent targets
yeah you avoid some of the you know the
coincidence registration
um problems that you have where you have
a fluorescent module off axis we just
need to characterize that a bit more and
be sure what our success will be
it's um maybe switch topics you're
getting a lot of questions about the the
sample itself so what is the size limit
of the sample down or nanometers that we
can extract the data from especially on
membrane complexes such as gpcr 100
kilodealans or less
because that's talking about in the
tomagrams in the end right so cry
legendary question so I mean typically
if you can identify a globular domain on
a protein within a membrane then you
might be able to do some subtle managing
for example that's why the double
receptor is quite a good Target for that
but if they're fully integral membranes
they're actually quite hard to do
because they have a very similar
contrast scale to the membrane itself
so in that instance the size is less
important than actually you know the
fact that it's embedded within the
liquid membrane well I think typically
if it's two fifty four buttons and above
it
probably had a chance to really identify
it and do some things and then I think
although that you know that becomes like
a
real research questions for computation
and uh different
um detection and algorithms
maybe this is the sample question I was
getting to so what um you mentioned that
you could study one samples all
organelles compared with um high
pressure freezing can you load the
obtained waffle grid directly on the
tomogram and use the plasma FIB for the
remaining steps or do you need to use
the cryo ultratome microulty tone
beforehand
yeah it's all right
I stopped because I made this more
sketch with the organize as a kind of
illustration what is possible to do I
mean it's possible to sandwich for
instance kids in the high pressure
freezer and kind of produce this type of
waffle or ice disk cuts and those can be
clipped into the tomocodes that can be
also clipped in regular Auto crits and
then processed of course if we have such
Pike amounts of ice we can really
utilize the plasma flip to really remove
the ice at faster rates it would be of
course appearing also to directly freeze
in the carriers for instance that's
something maybe for the future to come
but it's one way to kind of process
these sample it's not the only way to do
the another prep there are also other
ways to expose thicker samples and then
do some large lamella preparation I
didn't go into the details for that
um yeah you have noticed there's no lift
out system on the on the arctis at this
point the lifter is also another
technique which is really cool with with
that amount of throughput that we want
to generate there but I think there are
some in-roots with high pressure
prepared samples such as the the waffle
grids where that system can become
really interesting and especially if we
look into more bike tissues and it's
also something I think Michael has an
interest into
to look into a kind of biopsy and then
into the into that into more detail
yeah so I mean obviously limited by the
the freezing physics right so anything
that's two or 300 microns are bigger you
can't really
you have to then do some sectioning
beforehand
um but the plasma can be used at all the
steps I think as long as you have it uh
you know Frozen hydrated on a support
that is compatible with the instrument
then the plasma effect is quite
versatile in that regard
okay
um yeah straightforward question what is
the temperature of the sample in the FIB
all right the temperature is always that
we have to keep this the temperature of
course around liquid nitrogen
temperatures
so we are in the range of minus 180
degrees Celsius so to to be really on
the safe side that the sample is not
undergoing the phase transition from the
vitrus state into the uh a crystalline
state
okay
um I see that we're running out of time
so I think this will be the last
question today and we'll be sure to
answer any questions we didn't answer
um afterward correctly so last question
will be can you elaborate on why the
cryo TM contrast from plasma is better
than lamelling from traditional gallium
lamella
so so during the talk Alex mentioned
implantation right so that's one
potential theory that because gallium is
sort of full-time the atomic number of
the typical atoms you might expect to
find in a biological sample the implants
on the surface to a degree and uh that
ablates or reduces the contrast of the
generating the transmission electron
microscope
um but that's you know that's that's the
idea but that's a real that's an
experiment that we'd like to do using
something like eels idx where we try to
measure the amount of gallium on a
gallium generated lamella and compare
that to the other gases and an iron
coupled device
um the other one could be the the lower
con the lower contamination rates in the
in the actors itself so you know the
report and thickness really should be
um what the lamella thickness is without
an extra redeposit advice
that's kind of the two
two potential Moses that you know the
thickness we measure is really the
thickness we measure and traditional
mineral thicknesses
including uh including the ray deposited
layer as well that you can't really see
um so those are the two reasons I think
um I think of mainly
yeah we were just in the beginning also
understanding the damage mechanisms I
think Michael's and the crew take kind
of to the first start assessing also
damage for the plasma systems which is
important we now need to compare it also
for gallium where there's a bit more
simulation data there but not really
comparative data and maybe it's really
due to the fact that there's more
gallium implantation which kind of
hasn't has an influence on the high
frequency information that we can obtain
from this samples that makes a plasma
are kind of of beta but again it's kind
of early days and it's kind of we really
need to to look at that in in really
detail to to see what's um yeah what is
the uh yeah what is what are the real
differences there and how phones
especially damage kind of Compares
between plasma and gallium systems
okay well I want to thank you both for
your presentation today
um and unfortunately if we this is all
the time we have today and if we didn't
get to your question we'll be sure to
answer this by email I want to let
everyone to know that this webcast and
the others in our series can be viewed
on demand at lab Roots um you can also
register for upcoming events here
um we encourage you to share this
session with your colleagues who may
have missed today's event
um and if as much as we've enjoyed these
online events if you are in the Boston
area next week please join us on
September on 27th for an in-person
demonstration of one of our other cryo
TM tools the very Pacific scientific
Tundra
and as a last thank you to everyone if
you are still need more for
cryotomography in your day uh please
visit thermofisher.com forward slash
arctis you can download many
informations here about the the arctis
and see some additional videos and
before we go I just want to thank uh the
speakers again in the audience for
joining us
um and for all the interesting questions
that we answered if you have any
additional questions be sure to answer
them or you can use the Forum online on
the page to ask them as well so thank
you again for today's speakers to Alex
and Michael and especially to all of you
for joining us until next time
bye bye
thank you happy